this one road it's time
the story of Marilyn Monroe has been
told time and time again but blonde
definitely stands out from the crowd
from Anna De armas's incredible grounded
depiction of the star the unique way it
was filmed to the way they asked Marilyn
herself for permission to bring her back
to life
number one
stepping into the shoes of Marilyn
Monroe is no easy feat the cast and crew
of this movie got this big card and
wrote a message to the late Norma Jean
basically asking for her permission to
make the film and left the card on her
grave Anna De armas didn't take
Marilyn's position lightly she claims
they all felt her presence on set I
truly believe that she was very close to
us she was with us I think she was happy
she would also throw things off the wall
sometimes and get mad if she didn't like
something maybe this sounds very
mystical but it is true we all felt it
number two it took nine months to
perfect it just because it's so iconic
and so specific and English is not my
first language Anna did not shy away
from the hard work this film required
director Andrew Dominic had been
preparing for it for over 10 years he
actually asked me how much time do you
think you need and I was like well
forever she had a lot to catch up on she
worked with dialect coaches every every
day for several hours watched her films
and was always on YouTube watching
anything Marilyn Monroe she could find
number three
this might not seem like a big deal to
some but I just didn't leave home for
two months though painful for her to go
through it was necessary to really sell
the character they even took her to an
eyebrow specialist to get them
professionally done to mimic Marilyn's
brows not only that I like shaved the
middle of my eyebrows to make them more
separate them like she had the reason
why she didn't leave her house though
was because her hair was still brunette
so the whole thing just looked
incredibly awkward it was terrifying
number four there were five of them Ana
de armas was never going to color her
hair for the role of Marilyn not even
because she didn't want to but because
her hair wasn't the right texture Rob
Pickens the LA based wig maker and his
team spent over 150 hours hand making
each one when I say detail down to the
knot Maryland's Corners grew
horizontally so we tied those hairs
horizontally we looked like crazy people
sometimes with photos pinned all over
the wall all while we're tying
number five Ana de armas's eyes were
actually the one thing that made her
look similar to Marilyn Monroe Anna has
hazel eyes so she had to wear blue
contacts while filming she also had to
wear false lashes but only to weigh her
eyes down Tina Rossler Kerwin head of
the makeup Department discusses her
thought process behind the decision I
used a lot of lashes to weigh the
corners of dearmus's eyes down because
her eyes are a little bit bigger but the
lashes if you put enough of them on
it'll change the shape of your eye
number six to look that much like
Marilyn definitely took some time in the
makeup chair that was quite a journey
every day it was about three hours to
get ready every morning they relied
heavily on their Incredible Crew to
bring Marilyn to life we have over more
than 100 wardrobe changes in the movie
and they're all so beautiful and iconic
it was a challenge every day because the
film covers 36 years of Maryland's life
the crew had to effectively show that
time lapse in her costume hair and make
every day when we achieve that look and
we looked in the mirror and we knew we
got it was like really beautiful number
seven the cameras were always rolling
onadamus is not an actor who likes to
stay in character while the cameras are
off Andrew wanted to capture something
more spontaneous but the way Andrew
Dominic filmed the movie made that a
little difficult he had this thing that
he actually never caught
in between takes he even had his entire
crew dressed in clothes appropriate for
the time he would have that freedom of
let the camera follow me around set
there were a lot of improvised moments
captured on set as well as whenever she
would get her hair or makeup fixed or
get a note from her dialect coach if
there was someone from the crew in the
shot then it would be okay they were
dressed in in Period clothes number
eight
Anna De armas watched a ton of Marilyn
Monroe movies when she was behind the
camera Andrew Dominic had two monitors
pulled up one of her and one of the real
Marilyn in the scene she was recreating
they wanted every angle to be perfect so
of course that shot a ton of takes so on
a day armas has clocked hundreds of
hours of Marilyn Monroe movies under her
belt also being in every frame of the
entire movie Anna really felt the strain
of Marilyn Monroe's heavy character
it was exhausting I just cannot imagine
what it was like to be her number nine
you wouldn't be able to tell but this
movie was actually a rush job it was
done in just nine weeks which is a
ridiculously short amount of time to
film a movie that clocks in at almost
three hours we didn't have money we
didn't have time to do this to do the
movie it didn't help that they faced
several delays due to covid-19 and had
to push the release date back number 10.
if you know the story of Marilyn Monroe
you know it is very rarely a happy one
on a day armis felt this heaviness for
the entirety of the nine weeks she spent
working on the film she couldn't shake
it though she didn't go method and stay
in character when the cameras were off
her emotional well-being still took a
beating there was no way to unplug
because I'd get home and study for the
next day and then Andrew was on the
phone until midnight I would go to sleep
and dream I had long conversations with
her some days I would go home and have
dinner and as I was washing the dishes I
would just start sobbing crying and
crying because I had this terrible
feeling I knew I couldn't fix it Marilyn
Monroe only exists on the screen number
11. speaking of getting into character
let's talk about the first time Anna
looked in the mirror and saw Marilyn
Monroe everyone in the room started
crying I can tell you that it was it was
very emotional it was definitely a much
more surreal experience than the
Maryland costume she wore during her
audition I was just like driving down
Hollywood Boulevard with this very cheap
blonde wig and some kind of like makeup
but her first day on set everyone was
completely overwhelmed by how much like
Maryland she looked felt like
she was back or something I don't know
number 12 with great power comes great
responsibility anode armas admitted she
went through a lot of fear and
insecurity when playing this role most
of the time I thought I was doing it
wrong I was thinking what are these
American actors thinking of me they know
this person better than me they've grown
up with her what are they thinking about
my accent Andrew Dominic thought those
emotions were perfect that's it go with
it because that is literally what she's
going through as she could channel that
into her performance that is exactly
what she's feeling number 13. also known
as Mafia a fun fact about this film is
Anna De armas's 13 year old Maltese
Elvis is in a scene when I watch it I
don't know how to feel because of course
it's a very serious important scene in
the film and then at the same time I'm
just looking at him and I'm melting he
starred in two scenes but one of them
ended up being cut this isn't the first
time he's been on a film set apparently
he's so well behaved she's able to take
him to work quite often number 14.
Andrew Dominic had to get this movie
made blonde would never let me go for
years he would continue to think about
the movie and get new ideas for it even
Lynn Blum fell apart I'd still be
thinking about blondes after 10 years of
trying to make it happen he pushed
through all the delays lack of funding
and even the lack of time and finally
brought it to the big screen number 15.
Andrew Dominic isn't holding anything
back he thinks about what it would have
been like had the movie been released a
few years ago if it had come out a few
years ago it would have come out right
when me too hit and it would have been
an expression of all that stuff he
thinks that because it's being released
now it's definitely going to offend
everyone who watches it it's a film that
definitely has a morality about it but
it swims in very ambiguous Waters
because I don't think it will be as cut
and dry as people want to see it there's
something in it to offend everyone let
us know in the comments we you think
about the movie
blonde is a powerful fictional biopic
brought to life by the incredible
performance of Anna De armas the
passionate direction of Andrew Dominic
and a crew who can make miracles happen
even under the stunting pressure of time
what were you most surprised to find out
about the making of This film